bonjour meriem alors le gouvernement a
appelé au dialogue entre tous les
secteurs de la société à pois ce
dialogue peut-il aboutir concrètement
bonjour bas pour le moment on ne semble
pas encore en être au point du dialogue
il faudrait déjà que la répression
s'arrête ce qui ne semble pas du tout
être le cas le gouvernement d'extrême
droite libérale de divin duke et à
encourager la police et l'armée à
intervenir avec force après les
encouragements dans ce sens formulée par
son mentor l'ex président alvaro uribe
au pouvoir de 2002 à 2010 et dont
beaucoup d'opposants considère que celui
qui concerne dans l'ombre les forces de
l'ordre donc ont tiré à balles réelles
sur les manifestants on a pu voir à
travers les réseaux sociaux des images
terribles avec des individus qui ne
semblait pas représenté un quelconque
danger abattu à bout portant par les
forces de l'ordre
tous les jours on a eu des vidéos depuis
dix jours résultat l'om j'étais bloqué
ce qui recense les victimes a recensé
donc en dix jours 37 morts tués par
balles au moins 89 personnes portées
disparues plusieurs centaines de blessés
dont une vingtaine des borniers et une
dizaine d'agressions sexuelles
malgré tout cela malgré le danger donc
représentent les manifestations et
malgré la pandémie québec n'épargnait
pas du tout la colombie les utilisations
se continue de plus belle les
manifestants estiment que je cite le
gouvernement est plus dangereux que le
virus
la colère contre la réforme fiscale qui
était à la source de ce mécontentement
s'est transformé en brasier contre le
gouvernement vous le disiez à une
réforme à la source du mécontentement
quelles sont désormais les
revendications des manifestants et bien
déjà une grande colère face à cette
répression des forces de l'ordre dans la
fente iman de profonde injustice et une
grande hostilité contre le président
yvan duke et qu'ils ont plus bas dans
les sondages il ya ensuite la pauvreté
en colombie qui atteint des chiffres
record 40 % de la population colombienne
vit désormais sous le seuil de pauvreté
et 15% dans l'extrême pauvreté
c'est un des pays les plus inégalitaires
au monde selon de très nombreuses études
il ya aussi les effets de la pandémie
qui n'a pas épargné le pays comme je le
disais et le chômage qui envoie avoisine
les 16 % de la population
et enfin bien sûr la criminalité qui est
très forte en colombie un pays de grande
insécurité avec des assassinats de
leaders sociaux chaque jour les
colombiens ont nom a fait de la violence
et de la militarisation de la société
donc c'est tout ça qui dénoncent
désormais dans la rue et que dit la
communauté internationale face à ces
derniers événements alors l'onu a
condamné forme fermement la répression
et l'usagé excessif de la force en
ambiguïté en revanche washington en
général très bavarde et sans concession
quand il s'agit du venezuela de cuba de
la russie et des gouvernements qui ne
lui sont pas alignés n'a publié qu'un
seul communiqué sur la colombier
appelant sobrement au calme dénonçant la
répression bien sûr mais aussi certains
manifestation vieux manifestants pardon
violent et 10 ans à la fois faire
confiance dans le gouvernement des 28
hockey pour faire la lumière sur la
situation
elle lui a réitéré son soutien
l'administration américaine a réitéré
son soutien au gouvernement colombien
donc donc donc dans son unique
communiqué du 4 mai la porte parole du
département d'état a affirmé je cite
nous continuons d'appuyer les efforts du
colon du gouvernement colombien pour
faire face à la situation acquis actuels
par le dialogue politique
il faut dire que la colombie gouvernée
par la droite et l'extrême droite depuis
longtemps et depuis de nombreuses années
un allié précieux des états unis dans la
région
faut pas oublier qu'elle dispose que les
états unis dispose de pas moins de sept
bases militaires en colombie et les
gouvernements de droite qui se sont
succédé dans ce pays servent la
politique souvent d'ingérence des états
unis dans la région notamment contre les
gouvernements de gauche à cuba au
venezuela au nicaragua merci à même
rappelle que vous êtes notre journaliste
et spécialiste de l'amérique du sud
merci à vous